i can't believe i was the only person in
the theater sony heard us we wanted more
and they gave us more or should i say
morb
you sir you sir are you going to hashtag
sweep into the next showing they
re-released morbius because they knew it
was and will always be morbid please
stop saying morbid time meme's dead look
oh yeah it's dead like that wasn't even
funny it's pretty bad wanna get bagels
okay
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that loves to sink its teeth
into some juicy lore well theorists i
don't know about you but i've been to
the movies a lot in the past couple
months it's almost like there was a
two-year backlog of big movies that were
just waiting to roll out doctor strange
batman top gun sonic but few have risen
to the heights of morbius the movie that
truly brought cinema back from the brink
audiences critics even martin score says
he loved it made seven more billion
dollars at the box office and pretty
much everyone left theaters excited for
morbius 2 the empire bites back honestly
it's just shocking that sony decided to
hang on onto this masterpiece for over
two years the first trailer hid in
january of 2020. how could they justify
delaying this world altering work of art
for so long how confident are you that
the coronavirus came from bats probably
90 confident
oh yeah yeah that that would do it okay
so for understandable reasons sony
delayed morbius and then when they
finally did release it the movie was ugh
painfully mediocre let's fight somewhere
empty cut to morbius theater and when
the meme's making fun of this thing made
it the most talked about movie in the
world hollywood not understanding
internet sarcasm re-released it into
theaters and it was then and only then
that morbius finally did become the best
at something bombing at the box office
doing it not just once but twice anyway
it wasn't for any lack of trying the
trailer for this thing was everywhere
sony clearly used the same marketing
strategy that they used for the first
venom creating an air of mystery as to
if and how this film connected to the
larger marvel cinematic universe except
this time it was dialed up to 11. for
venom sony producer amy pascal just said
that well those movies will all take
place in the world that we are now
creating for peter parker so there is a
chance that and tom holland will pop up
somewhere over there just watch kevin
feige's face in this thing slowly dying
from the inside knowing none of this is
real anyway for more bs marketing really
dialed up hyping up the connections to
spider-man venom and mcu they even
straight up name drop venom in what is
clearly the funniest joke ever put to
celluloid i
am
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
he's michael morvious but he's
pretending
he's not eddie brock
oh it's so funny and that's not all
either we also see a poster of
spider-man labelled a murderer clearly
referencing the cliffhanger from far
from home except this isn't tom
holland's web head it's actually the
tobey mcguire costume from the
playstation video game then there's a
building with oscorp logo from andrew
garfield's amazing spider-man with
another shot focusing on the maguire
version of the daily bugle newspaper not
only that but two of the bugle's
headlines here tease the villain's rhino
and black cat most obviously though
michael keaton pops up as adrian toombs
aka the vulture from homecoming further
teasing a direct connection to tom
holland's version of the wall crawler
honestly all of this left theorists like
me wondering how they were going to
connect all these dots but if you went
into morbius expecting any answers about
the easter eggs too bad most of them
aren't in the movie no spidey poster no
ozcorp no osbournes and all those hints
and cameos might as well not have been
in there either the daily bugle
newspaper was just a throwaway prop
morbius's venom joke strangely had its
punchline cut but not the reference to
venom most bafflingly the vultures
scenes from the trailer aren't in the
movie instead we get a different pair of
intriguing post-credit scenes where
vulture spontaneously materializes in
the more of a verse and meets up with
jared leto in a way that doesn't even
follow the rules set up by the
[Music]
i mcu the food's better in this joint
i'm not sure how i got here has to do
with spider-man i think now morbius is
hardly the first movie to have altered
scenes for the trailer marvel studios is
actually infamous for doing things
exactly like this they've altered shots
of everything from thor ragnarok to
spider-man no way home to avengers
infinity war to hide spoilers they've
even fabricated shots that didn't appear
in their movies like this shot of hulk
running alongside the avengers from
infinity war but i think the difference
here is that these shots were altered to
hide major plot points sony meanwhile
these were fundamentally manufactured
scenes purely meant to build hype off of
nothing and if you were there
specifically to see what came of the
easter eggs in the trailers well it's
entirely fair that you could feel lied
to and a lot of people here on youtube
they were very vocal about feeling lied
to the thing that
generated the most hype for this movie
at the end of the day is people going
like which universe does this take place
and it is manipulative let's put like a
spider-man poster in the background or
something and then we put that in the
trailer but it's not going to make sense
in the movie we don't have to put it in
the movie and it feels like false
advertising yeah let's do some of that
honestly it kind of borders on false
advertising basically it had people
asking so why'd you do it i can't answer
that and seeing all this discussion got
me thinking was the movie actually
falsely advertised did morbius break the
law did they play a little too fast and
loose with the trailers and misrepresent
what was in the movie and most
importantly of all could sony be sued
for that so grab your blood bags and
take a big ol slurp loyal theorists
today we're about to find out also just
as a friendly reminder none of this is
meant to be actual legal advice kind of
like this guy from morbius i don't
remember you ever finished in law school
cause i didn't so first let's talk about
what exactly false advertising is how is
it legally defined like all laws it
varies from place to place in the united
states advertising is regulated
nationwide by the federal trade
commission or the ftc who prohibit quote
unfair or deceptive acts or practices in
or affecting commerce false
advertisement is fittingly enough
exactly what it says on the tin you
can't run ads that outright lie and
trick consumers into thinking your
product is something that it isn't or
does something that it isn't meant to do
makes sense right so let's break down
the legalese piece by piece to see what
applies to morbius shall we let's start
with deceptive practices legally
speaking these are defined using three
points showing your product in a way
that misleads the consumer the
consumer's interpretation is reasonable
and the misleading information is
withheld until the consumer has already
made their purchase if you want a
clear-cut example of this in 1996 hasbro
had to pay the ftc a fine of 280
thousand dollars because they used air
compressed paint guns to film this
commercial for their color blaster toy
instead of using the actual toy which in
turn created a deceptive representation
of what the toy actually did now this
one seems like it might have some legs
to stand on against morbius right i mean
if you look at the trailers it'd be
pretty hard to argue that they're not
deceptive a representation that misleads
check the trailer has a vandalized
spider-man poster directly implying a
link to the events from far from home
and then the poster isn't present in the
final product reasonable consumer
interpretation check again it's in the
trailer so it's reasonable to expect it
to wind up in the final movie misleading
information withheld until after
purchase check one final time you aren't
gonna know these connections were cut or
changed until after you buy a ticket to
see the movie so that is three for three
across the board which means that the
studio execs should probably be shaken
in their boots right well what about the
other half of the legal definition
unfair practices is also defined by
three key points it's an act which can
hurt consumers it cannot be reasonably
avoided and it's not outweighed by any
of the other benefits provided by the
product or its competition again if
you'd like a clear-cut example of this
in 2019 the ftc sued match.com for
unfair practices match had notified
their users that they'd caught the eye
of a potential suitor but many of the
likes and messages that they used
originated from accounts that they knew
were likely fraudulent this led to
almost 500 000 people paying for
subscriptions to see those likes and
messages and those subscriptions were
often difficult to cancel basically the
ftc alleged that match used the scammers
on its site which could be as high as 25
to 30 percent of their accounts as
marketing to sell subscriptions it was
unfair it was hurtful and there was no
real benefit gained to the consumers but
how would any of this apply to morbius
well it's a good question this one's
actually a bit more ambiguous than
deceptive practices so let's go through
point by point did morbius hurt
consumers legally probably not but
sitting through that thing was pretty
painful could you have reasonably
avoided the deceptive morbius trailers
maybe it's possible that you could have
gone into morbius blind but sony also
spent a lot of money running their
trailers on tv in front of other movies
during youtube videos for over two years
if you were watching pretty much any
piece of pop culture since 2019 you
likely saw this trailer so for this
criteria i'd say probably guilty finally
did morbius cause substantial injury to
consumers without providing benefit
again it's a tricky question you might
have been lied to about the contents of
the movie but you still wound up with a
movie that is some level of benefit
provided by the product as for the level
of harm sure at face value it's like a
10 ticket but what if someone took a day
off of work or hired a babysitter do
those things qualify as substantial
injury well you might be surprised to
hear that the answer could be yes in
2014 the ftc settled a lawsuit with red
bull after they were sued for falsely
advertising that their drink could
provide performance-enhancing benefits
when there were no scientific studies to
back that fact up they were required to
provide anyone who bought their product
within a certain time range with either
a 10 reimbursement or 15 in credit for
other red bull products so it's not like
the ftc isn't willing to go after
products that are relatively cheap like
say movie tickets so well definitely not
as clear-cut as deceptive practices
seems like a case could also be made
that morbius engaged in unfair practices
as well in total that winds up being
about four to five points out of a
possible six against morbius so i asked
the question again did sony falsely
advertise this movie well there's
certainly a lot of gray area there is a
very good argument that you could make
that they did but is it enough to get
the studio in trouble could you sue sony
over the trailers for morbius and again
i stress this is not legal advice but
yes technically you could do that i mean
let's be honest with ourselves you can
sue practically anyone over anything the
problem with doing that is just you're
gonna lose a lot of those cases but in
the case of suing movie companies for
movie trailers you wouldn't be the first
in fact a case is actually working its
way through the court system right now
in january of this year 2022 two men
filed a class-action lawsuit against
universal pictures alleging that they'd
both rented the film yesterday based on
the brief appearance of actress anna de
armas in the trailers however she wasn't
actually in the movie so now the men are
seeking 5 million dollars in damages wow
just to make this clear the armist
appeared for like 13 seconds in one of
yesterday's trailers and now they want 5
million dollars now while de armas did
film scenes for yesterday the subplot
with her role was ultimately cut out of
the finished film very late in the
production process to help focus the
story given the recency of this case
it's yet to be resolved so sadly we
don't know if any precedent set by this
case would affect things here but even
these guys weren't the first to bring
forward this sort of lawsuit in 2011 a
woman sued the studio film district over
the ryan gosling movie drive which she
alleged was promoted as being similar to
the fast and furious franchise basically
she thought the trailers made it look
like a high-speed action driving film
however the woman walked away from drive
thinking that it was neither fast nor
furious enough instead focusing
primarily on slow-paced interpersonal
drama so there you have it friends there
is legal precedent for suing movie
companies over what you perceive to be a
misleading trailer so is it morbid time
to call a lawyer well probably not and
not because you'd be wrong but rather
because it's probably not worth your
time first of all because there's such a
little precedent here we have no idea
how the ftc would rule regarding morbius
according to the california-based
spencer law firm there's already an
expectation that footage in a trailer
may or may not make it into a film
because they're made so long before the
final cut is solidified they argue that
it's not necessarily the job of a
trailer to show exactly what's going to
be in the movie but rather the tone and
feel of the movie that's an argument
that the ftc might find persuasive
additionally what little legal precedent
there is for suing movie studios over
their trailers wouldn't exactly be on
your side that woman who sued the studio
behind drive well if you've ever watched
drive you'll know that the woman isn't
wrong about what the movie is drive
isn't devoid of action but it is very
slow and yet the case got dragged out in
one form or another until 2018 when
every judge presiding over it concluded
that drive did accurately advertise the
amount of violence action and drama in
the film now that lawsuit was focused on
the movie's tone rather than any
misleading content removed from the
trailers so there may be more of a leg
to stand on here to sue morbius but
perhaps the biggest question of all is
whether the ftc would care in the first
place you see last year on our sister
location game theory we covered the
onslaught of misleading and false
advertisements in the mobile gaming
space where we saw that the ftc tends to
look especially closely at advertising
claims that affect consumers health and
their pocketbooks we basically concluded
that while yes these games were falsely
advertised the ftc has far bigger fish
to fry for morbius maybe you spent 15 or
20 bucks on the ticket that lawsuit
against match.com meanwhile some of
those unfairly advertised subscriptions
were costing people hundreds of dollars
as for that color blaster toy we
mentioned sure the toy itself wasn't
super expensive but the ftc is
especially concerned with advertisements
aimed at kids they require that these
sorts of commercials aimed at children
have clear delineation between what the
toy can really do versus the fantasy of
the advertisement meanwhile
advertisements aimed at adults or older
kids like the pg-13 audience of morbius
well the ftc doesn't seem to think that
companies need to treat their consumers
like idiots and they've thrown out
several cases based on the idea that
reasonable consumers should be able to
figure some of this stuff out like here
is this all butter loaf cake misleading
because it wasn't made entirely from
butter well no according to the ftc
people should know better especially
when all the ingredients are also listed
on the packaging instead they tend to
focus on bigger falsehoods like
volkswagen claim that their diesel cars
are environmentally friendly in that
case the ftc required volkswagen to pay
up to 14.7 billion dollars in buybacks
lease terminations and vehicle
modifications for affected customers if
the ftc were to find sony guilty and
force them to do similar refunds for
morbius movie that bombed at the box
office twice in less than two months it
would be for about one percent of what
they mandated for volkswagen and even
then it's entirely possible that the ftc
would settle with sony for an amount far
lower than the 73 million dollars the
movie made in the us and canada the case
that the ftc brought against a red bull
for example that one was settled for a
total of just 13 million dollars and
that was supposed to account for anyone
in america that bought a red bull in the
12-year period between 2002 and 2014 and
even then actually getting the money
back might not even happen just this
year in march of 2022 a judge ruled that
match.com didn't have to pay
844 million dollars of what the ftc
sought in their lawsuit against them
because of a legal loophole they
reasoned that match.com was only
publishing the misleading third-party
content instead of actually generating
it themselves now obviously none of the
cases we've talked about here line up
one-to-one with morbius even the
lawsuits about movie trailers the
specifics of how a suit against morbius
would go down how much money sony would
have to refund even if they were found
guilty in the first place are all up in
the air we just don't know because there
isn't that much legal precedent for this
sort of a case but the point here is
that this thing would be a labyrinthine
legal nightmare that's before you even
attempt to educate an elderly judge
about the multiversal implications of
spider-man no way home can you imagine
i'd like to present to the court the
following piece of evidence spider-man
killing mysterio but he doesn't really
kill mysterio it was actually caused by
illusion drones but everyone thinks he
killed mysterio which is why everyone
calls him a murderer and why those
posters in the trailer from morbius
matter so much and that's also why
doctor strange opens up the multiverse
to erase everyone's memories which is
how you get that venom joke and also why
vulture are there but it's not actually
following the official mcu rules and i
went into this movie expecting it to be
the official mcu rules clearly you see
why i was misled i rest my case and i
rest my theory my film theory and cut
[Music]
you